i know this was a while ago but remember  that time you said i looked like baron  zemo with a liberal arts degree it  really hurt my feelings bro that was  like a year ago i didn't know i was  living in your head rent-free all this  time  where are you living  hi is this the state of california i  have a tenant that's been living in my  head rent free for uh up to 12 months  they haven't been paying their rent i've  been a good landlord i called pest  control last month  carol how did you handle your 2006  tenants well that's not very helpful  i'd like to speak to the sheriff of the  city if the law is on my side i mean  they find a way to evict the tenant in  my ah  i think it's gonna work out now  [Music]  also i like broke the stove